[Music]
think back to the last time you were in
a hospital
what do you see maybe you walk through
clear glass doors into a gleaming white
Lobby you see doctors and white coats
stethoscopes draped around their necks
you see nurses in blue scrubs something
a little bit like this maybe you haven't
actually been in a hospital in a little
while but you've watched a lot of Grey's
Anatomy in-house and so you can just
picture those same doctors and nurses
flirting off in corners of the hospital
solving medical mysteries well I've
spent the last five years working in and
with hospitals and that's not what I see
in fact every time I would walk into a
new hospital I would go to the door and
put my hand out for the handle and I
would hesitate before I opened do I
really want to go inside hospitals have
a problem and this problem is killing us
ninety nine thousand ninety nine
thousand people every year are killed by
this problem in the United States one in
twenty one in twenty patients who
stepped foot into a hospital will be
affected by this problem what is this
problem do you know it's not common
knowledge there's a good chance that you
don't hospital acquired infections
hospital acquired infections or
infections that a person did not have
prior to entering the hospital in which
they would not have otherwise contracted
had they not been in the hospital they
are almost entirely preventable and yet
in 2020 they will kill ninety nine
thousand people in the United States
that's one person every five minutes
that's two times the number of people
who would be killed in car accidents
this year that's three times the number
of people who'll be killed by guns in
the United States in 2020 how can the
happen well there is a system that is
broken in the hospital and I'm gonna
show you what that is so let's think
again about our hospital here we walk
inside and we look around and there's
something that we cannot see and it's
everywhere
in the hospital germs but these aren't
your normal germs these are not the
germs that you'll find down at Starbucks
or at your local office building these
germs are what are called superbugs and
these superbugs go by many names MRSA
Clostridium difficile or c-diff Candida
Oris CRE VRE and they are deadly to put
this in perspective for you everybody
now knows about this 2019 novel
coronavirus well if you catch the corona
virus you have a 2% chance of dying if
you catch Mirza or c-diff or Candida or
us or one of these other superbugs you
have up to a 30% chance of dying these
superbugs are also widespread so as of
today March 3rd 2020 approximately
90,000 people have been infected with
the corona virus and that's worldwide
but just this year in just in the United
States 1.7 million people will be
infected with one of these superbugs
that leads to a hospital-acquired
infection so you don't need to get into
a plane and fly off to Wuhan or you
don't need to get into a cruise ship
that's stuck off the coast of Japan to
be exposed to some of the world's
deadliest germs all you have to do is
get into a car and drive down to your
local hospital so let's come back again
to our hospital here
it's a beautiful hospital and we walk
inside there's something that we don't
see when we're in this hospital what we
don't see is the people who are
dedicated to cleaning up the superbugs
I'm gonna call these people are
superheroes and who are these
superheroes are they our doctors or our
nurses our hospital administrators no
our superheroes are the environmental
services staff they are the janitors and
the housekeeper
of the hospital so I'm gonna tell you a
story about one of these superheroes her
name is Marie so Marie is a mother of
four children she works three jobs
part-time jobs at minimum wage just to
barely make ends meet she tells herself
she can keep it all together but she's
exhausted
she's probably slept on average about
four hours every night for the past God
knows how many weeks but she's not just
exhausted from the lack of sleep she's
exhausted from the heroic job that she
does in the hospital so let's take a
minute to consider everything that Marie
needs to do every time she walks into a
new hospital patient room to clean it
and she has to do this over and over
again throughout the day so Marie walks
into this hospital room she has to strip
the linens from the bed she then has to
inspect the mattress make sure that
there are no punctures or holes or other
issues of the mattress that's very
important shannon has to remake the bed
with fresh linens she then has to
disinfect every single surface within
that hospital room so everything from
the light switches the doorknobs the
bedside table the over bed table the bed
rails just to disinfect pull cords all
of the metal medical equipment any
chairs in their arm rails she then has
to go into the bathroom and she has to
disinfect the sink the faucet the drain
the toilet the guard rails on the side
of the of the toilet she then has to
disinfect the pool cords in there and
then disinfect and mop the floor in the
patient room and in the bathroom how
much time do you think we should give
superhero Marie to do this job and I'll
give you a hint so in the hotel industry
housekeepers are given on average 30
minutes to turn a room in between guests
but it hotels are not a critical care
environment hotels don't have patients
in hospitals marie is only given ten
minutes just ten minutes to change this
patient room and do all those critical
things that need to be done ten minutes
just imagine the next time you go into a
hotel you think that the housekeeper
only took ten minutes in between
cleaning cleaning the room between you
and the prior guests now imagine that
that prior guests had a deadly colon
infection I mean those rooms were not
clean it's really disgusting so there's
something else that you don't see about
Marie and that is that she is not
respected in this hospital and neither
has her job just yesterday she was
yelled at by a nurse for not turning an
operating room quickly enough even
though she knew that moving any faster
would seriously compromise patient
safety Marie also has not been given the
right tools for her job she's been given
disinfectants that are ineffective
they're the cheapest possible
disinfectants and they don't work
against the superbugs that were
concerned about she's given mops and
wipes that come back from the laundry
contaminated
she just reintroduces whatever she took
out yesterday back into the hospital
environment
Marie was also never trained properly
the prevalent feeling among hospital
administrators is why would we invest in
training people for this role this is
easy anybody can do it it's not
important all of these things the lack
of a proper paycheck the lack of respect
the lack of tools and lack of training
and the lack of it but enough staff to
actually do this job right has
contributed to an environment where
Marie just hates this job how could she
not how can you blame her all of these
factors are within a hospital's control
and yet nothing is done about this and
in fact the very first place that most
hospitals look when they want to trim
their budget is that the Environmental
Services Department so where does this
leave us okay on the one hand we have
our superbugs that are extremely deadly
on the other hand we have our
superheroes and we've created a
situation where we have tied this hands
of our superheroes behind their backs we
have made it in
possible for them to do their job it's
no wonder that the superbugs are winning
in this battle versus these superheroes
all of this right now
is abstract this isn't real but the
consequences of this are real so let me
show you what you can see this is Emma
grace brew Emma contracted a Merce
infection when she was a newborn at a
hospital in Louisiana she the twin
brother her twin brother also contracted
an infection he died when he was 14 days
old but Emma lived on she had permanent
damage to her legs her wounds in her
heart she was in and out of the hospital
for the first few years of her life when
she was three-and-a-half she went back
into the hospital for yet another
surgery to her leg this time when she
was in the hospital she contracted
pneumonia the doctors told her parents
that because the mersa had so devastated
her immune system when she was a newborn
there was probably nothing they could do
and in fact Emma died just days shy of
her fourth birthday and this this is
what happens every five minutes but
there is hope there is something that we
can do so for the past five years I've
been working on a company that addresses
some of these issues and I know what
you're thinking we're sitting here in
Silicon Valley there must be some sort
of high-tech solution to this problem
but what I love about this solution is
that it can be low-tech so my company we
developed a platform of tools and
training that we could actually plug in
to a hospital to help address those two
issues out of the five that I mentioned
earlier and just by addressing those two
issues we were able to reduce infections
by over 30% and all the hospitals that
we worked with but I'm not here to talk
about my company I'm here to talk about
the three things that I think all of us
in this room can do to actually make a
difference and help solve this
problem so what are those three things
the first thing is awareness that's what
we're doing here right now we need to
talk about this issue we need to shine a
light on it hospitals have a vested
interest in keeping this issue in the
dark and it's up to all of us to bring
it out of the shadows and into the light
of day the second thing we need to do we
need to get hospitals to change how they
deal with their environmental services
department we need them to fix these
issues and take them seriously and then
we need to hold them accountable for
doing that so how can you hold the
hospital accountable there are now great
resources online Hospital Compare is one
of the best it's put together by the
government and you can actually go on to
this website and you can compare your
local hospital versus a regional and
national benchmarks and see how it
stacks up in terms of infection rates we
all have to remember that we are
consumers of healthcare as patients and
as the loved ones of patients we need to
send a message to hospitals that is
customers we can take our business
elsewhere
if they don't shape up and fix this
infection issue and the third thing we
need to do comes down to respect so I
mentioned that my company has a training
component to it one of our best trainers
who works with the Environmental
Services staff in the hospital told me a
story that totally changed my
perspective on this and so he told me
that in the when he would go into the
hospital he was having a lot of trouble
he felt like he wasn't getting through
to these environmental services staff to
the janitors and the housekeeper's and
he did one simple thing at the beginning
of each training session that totally
changed the mindset in that room and
shifted how he interacted with the
housekeeper's in the training sessions
he started each session by saying
purpose over paycheck purpose over
paycheck and just those three things
totally changed the dynamic and I think
what he did was he was showing respect
he was showing respect for the
environmental services workers and
showing them that they have a purpose in
this job and it is important and so I
think the next time all of you are in
the hospital you should say thank you
when you see the janitor or the
housekeeper in that Hospital show them
in the respect they deserve in
and show them that you understand the
incredibly important role that they have
in keeping patients safe thank you
[Applause]
[Music]